bonjour merci d'être avec nous bon
réveil c'est la rentrée
une semaine les gens
bon courage aux enseignants bon courage
aux enfants qui se lèvent donc
d'habitude ce matin on espère que ça va
bien se passer c'est là
mais c'est aussi la rentrée pour des
millions de collégiens de lycéens
d'enfants tout court on pense à vous on
pense aussi aux parents qui nous
regardent ne me force pas
[Musique]
l'entrée dans la cour des grands un jour
particulier pour ses élèves de cours
préparatoire comptant de se retrouver
elle va apprendre à lire
à écrire aussi mais c'est trop bien
sinon j'ai quand même un petit souci
faut y aller maintenant
vous allez voir Marie au bout de trois
semaines vous aurez trouvé le rythme
c'est l'affaire de 2 ans regardez un
autre type de réveil qui lui alors là on
peut rien y faire alors si vous êtes un
peu un peu d'installation parce qu'il ça
s'installe dans le dans le sommier et
quand on appelle son enfant eh
réveille-toi s'il faut aller à l'école
l'enfant dort toujours et bien là on
parle de son enceinte connectée on dit
active le mode réveil extrême et là le
réveil c'est le tremblement
à 4 jours de l'ouverture de la Coupe du
monde de rugby Emmanuel Macron est venu
au soutien du 15 de France le chef de
l'État les a rejoints dans leur camp de
base du ruelle Malmaison elle les a
assurés de la pluie dès 67 millions de
français dans un discours enflammé
vous êtes l'équipe la mieux préparée au
monde il y a pas de place pour
l'économie et c'est de la première à la
dernière minute il faut tout donner on
cesse français mes chers compatriotes la
rentrée de TPMP c'est le 4 septembre
vous trouverez évidemment Raymond
l'abominable de Ragis Kelly Vedovelli
Delphine
Géraldine maillet la donneuse de leçon
Valou valeur
et Gilles Verdez malheureusement et la
présentation l'homme au mollessaillant à
l'épiderme exemplaire je parle bien sûr
de Cyril Hanouna
18h12 nous sommes le 4 septembre 2023 et
à l'heure où nous parlons on a toujours
aucune nouvelle de l'homme qu'on appelle
la pépite du PAF baba ou plus
communément Cyril Hanouna mais la
polémique qui a agité cette rentrée bah
c'est vous qui en est à l'origine
monsieur le ministre quand vous avez
lancé l'opération à Baya ah bah il y a
plus
donc
une rentrée scolaire sous surveillance
dans certains établissements comme ici
dans ce lycée de Lyon aucune élève ne
rentre vêtue d'une habaya cette robe
longue traditionnelle qui couvre le
corps contrôle systématique à l'entrée
l'élève qui arrive dans une tenue qui ne
respecte pas la loi ne sera pas
autorisée à aller en classe ce rappel à
la loi de 2004 sur la laïcité n'aura pas
lieu devant les caméras pour cette jeune
fille à droite en Aya cette longue robe
ample qui ne laisse apparaître que les
mains et le visage une fois passé la
porte elle est prise à part pour un
entretien l'autoritarisme n'a aucun sens
pour les élèves et ça renforcerait le
sentiment liberticide qui peuvent vivre
parfois j'en ai marre de cette
République où l'on stigmatise les
musulmans
qu'est-ce que vous
allez
rep
Rochez faire de d'opérer un repli
communautaire vous allez leur reprocher
de ne pas chanter la Marseillaise
ils vont dire que la République n'est
plus la leur donc revenez à la raison
pensez aux musulmans
sauf que je sais pas si vous êtes plus
idiocutile ou l'inverse dans une société
où il y a plus de professeurs on est
dans une société où les professeurs
manquent cruellement on est dans une
société où il y a des gens qui
n'arrivent plus à bouffer qui n'arrivent
plus à payer leurs factures et on est en
train de se poser la question de savoir
si la bagarre va être respectée ainsi de
ne pas porter la Baya va être respecté
ou pas mais on s'en fout en fait cette
dame madame berger blackaire elle n'est
pas invitée là où elle pourrait être
invitée vous ne l'avez pas France Inter
vous ne l'avez pas chez Madame Salamé
vous ne le verrez pas cette célèbre
émission qui reprend ce soir avec son
animateur et vous n'avez pas vous
toujours mais non mais
on leur dit bonjour on est en sous-sol
mais au dessus à déménager la semaine
dernière juste au dessus devinez qui
c'est pas une blague c'est news oui
c'est News a déménagé juste au dessus de
nous piles au dessus on est on va
peut-être se croiser maintenant parce
qu'on est dans le même ils sont pas loin
ils sont pas loin on peut leur donner
les extraits directement s'ils veulent
devant la maison bon Christian Estrosi
maire de Nice ma ville Nissa la Bella
qui a organisé sa traditionnelle
bamboche des amis du maire en compagnie
cette année dans l'invité exceptionnelle
moi-même Édouard Balladur
Philippe et en même temps si c'était ça
la solution pour sauver la droite je
lance tout degault le hashtag Baladur
2027 à vos clavier Luc Legé
familièrement faire une bourde bienfait
oui il y a la piste de la fugue mais qui
a été a priori assez rapidement
abandonné parce qu'il y a un enfant de 2
ans et demi il va pas parcourir 10 km à
pied il y avait une carte bleue
[Musique]
oui ça ça m'arrangerait le 5
évite les trous de balle
non
c'est aussi des chemins
[Rires]
et donc j'ai l'honneur de vous annoncer
que le gilet c'était donc bien lui qui
évite les trous de balle le gilet par
balle
j'ose même pas imaginer ce qui vous est
passé par la tête oh oh oh oh oh c'est
quoi ça encore
confondu Queen Bee Elizabeth vous savez
pourquoi je vous parle de